Jute is a plant fiber
that spun into strong,
coarse twine for
traditional Basque
espadrilles. They use
twine that's about a 10th
of an inch thick.
Large jute spools feed
an automated braiding
machine. Its five
bobbins move in a
circular pattern that
produces a neat braid,
measuring roughly three
fourths of an inch wide
by a quarter of an inch
thick.
Right after exiting the
braiding machine, the
braid enters a
calibration machine,
which applies tension to
make the dimensions
uniform. Each espadrille
sole is handcrafted by an
artisan. He winds the
braid on a form that's
more than a century old.
The positioning of the
metal pegs in the holes
correspond to the size
of the shoe he's making.
The closer the pegs are
to each other, the
smaller the shoe size.